Dan Wetzel yahoo sports national
columnist usually writing great things
about what's going on with the NCAA and
he joins us now to give us the Cliff
Notes version dan good morning thanks
for joining us what do we need to know
about this and why does it bother you so
much well I don't think I think it's a
product of a slow news timing quite you
know we need you know Armageddon here
anything like that
okay asically the NCAA is saying they
have players if players that want to
test the draft waters after their their
college season they are now allowed to
you know make an agreement with a
representative an agent or somebody who
can then say you know call teams you
know where do you think my guys going to
be drafted right so if the teams come
back say yeah late second round or not
at all hey maybe stay in school they
said they'd say hey your top five got
right pretty basic what the NCAA is
saying is in order to for if you're
going to hire one of those guys this
agent has to have passed their
certification test and the
certifications includes a bachelor's
degree
you've already been an agent with the
NBPA for three years certified there you
have to come to Indianapolis and take
some kind of test from the NCAA about
you know rules and things like that
they're basically you know just
regulating this on the on the back end
and so it got attention because rich
Paul LeBron James agent and Davises
agent Duram our greens agent does not
have a bachelor's degree and so LeBron
and others think well hey this is about
snuffing out rich Paul and stopping him
from being able to do this and there
certainly I think a pretty good argument
of like why do you need a bachelor's
degree to do this okay there's no
classes and how do you figure out where
guys can draft it I don't know any
majors and that in university look maybe
someone should do it so that's kind of
why it flared up I think it's it's a
stupid kind of rule it's arbitrary who
cares it's a bachelor's degree why
it's one thing for a league or a union
to regulate the agents particularly a
union
yeah regulated agents that are getting
representing but colleges are trying to
keep these guys like they're like they
shouldn't have any say and what a kid
wants to do if he's thinking of leaving
so it's almost like it's just an extra
regulation and an effort to keep players
in school do you think this is point you
know a rule that is targeting ridgepole
I actually don't I get why that's a
thought but rich Paul is a major player
and he's a major agent and what we're
dealing with here are agents that would
be trying to sign borderline
second-round draft picks like guys on
you know second-round or back zion
Williamson does not need an agent to
tell him hey where do you think I might
get drafted okay he knows so rich Paul
is not out there trying to sign guys
that you know plays four years or three
years of Purdue and trying to so I went
on a fourth year or not true so I'll and
do it Ricky has more to do with
Christian Dawkins and who was in the you
know the college basketball scandal
trials and guys like that and they're
coming up the next rich Paul but it's
mainly just at the NCAA just you know
overstepping this thing look if you have
your say your players are amateurs
they're just students they're not
workers they're not employees you've
fought in federal court for that
designation because you don't want all
that comes with it well if you're an
amateur at something you should have
more freedom not less okay if you're
just an amateur golfer you shouldn't
have to obey by the rules of the of the
PGA Tour something because who cares
right you don't think it drug tested or
I don't know whatever the heck that all
the rules are you should be easy have
more freedom and so for them to x-play
to put regulations on the on the on the
back end of this in addition to what the
MVPA already does to me you know strikes
is heavy-handed it's also just
unnecessary and just it just it seems
like rules for the sake of rules but I
don't really think it's about rich Paul
no offense to LeBron
and I think it's you know it's a little
heated I think the NCAA needs to redo
how they kind of handle
stuff yeah we're talking to Dan Wetzel
Yahoo Sports national columnist yeah I
started to look at this like oh why is
the NCAA involved in somebody's
financial future here after they leave
or you want to make sure they stay if we
get done through with a one-and-done
rule then you know how important is this
rule going to be Dan well it could be
big it's the same thing because coming
out of high school you would want to
hire someone and say where am I getting
drafted should I go to should I go to
Duke
or should I go right to the league and
obviously if you're saying hey you're
gonna get picked you know Ethan the
draft you know what I'm gonna go to the
league or you know this guy has the
connection to say hey you know San
Antonio is going to take you at this
place at this spot or so the decision is
the exact same it's just whether you
even show up here's my thing with this
whole bit and it's why I find it
infuriating is certainly you know
penological is in hockey okay the other
winter sport with a major professional
league where people make millions of
dollars a plot everybody is eligible for
the NHL draft you don't the declare for
the draft it's a slight distinction but
you get drafted in hockey you get
drafted and then you can decide whether
or not you want to go to college you
don't lose your eligibility by staying
in the NHL draft or even getting drafted
the Player of the Year last year kale
maker from who plays for the Colorado
Avalanche now he was drafted fourth
overall in 2017 then he decided you know
I think college would be best for me and
he went to UMass for two years and then
joined the Avalanche so a hockey player
can get drafted and retain eligibility
but a basketball player can lose their
eligibility just by hiring an agent to
consider whether to go in the draft okay
that isn't certified by hence yet these
are these are students under their
parlance these are student athletes
under the at the same athletic
department like you can walk in the same
Hall on the same trainer same building
everything's the same same school same
rule book yet the hockey player gets one
role a quad which i think is a good one
because they
sit there and say you know I don't like
it and draft it here I thought I was
going to get drafted and I didn't why
should I have to not go back to college
like who does that help just in tears a
sorry kid haha you didn't get in you
thought you were getting picked and you
got picked late for God man they picked
me but they got too many powerful words
on a long play there I'll wait and I'll
try to get better and and then I'll play
for them later so that's my problems we
have one rule for hockey players and one
completely more strict rule for
basketball players one of those sports
makes somebody a lot of that's what it
comes down to that's why I said they're
trying to protect a multi-billion dollar
business called March Madness that's
that's all they care about if if hockey
made money if the Frozen Four made money
then maybe they'd get involved in this
if the college world series made money
then maybe they'd be more involved in
that that's what it comes down to that's
why you know the NFL loves having these
college football players or the colleges
love having these football players for
at least three years you know it's it's
great you you you know you get these guy
know they're not ready to go to the NFL
but this is a multi-billion dollar
business where you get to keep stars
around for a little while longer if they
did a real comprehensive reform it was
it was best for the players and their
families but also I think the best for
keeping kids in college let them get
drafted let's say you get picked by San
Antonio okay your 25th pick of the draft
and go I just don't know that I'm ready
I want to go back to college and you get
and Gregg Popovich says that's fine go
play for Duke this year you know what
we're gonna answer is gonna allow you to
come play in our summer league in just
in Vegas like an internship we pay you
or something like that but then ya go to
college get a year or two maybe three
maybe you never pan out and this is a
bad pic but you stay all four years and
get your degree how is it a bad thing to
try to keep kids in college like the
hockey system works great there's
literally no one in hockey and I don't
know we don't pay attention to it but
you know the coat they're all in there
nobody's complaining about the hockey
system they like it it's good for
everybody
it is good it's good for for these
schools to have the kid there
Ryan Donato
three years at Harvard then went to the
Olympics and then joined the Boston
Bruins right after Harvard was
eliminated from from the playoffs a
couple years ago now he's with Minnesota
like these are all good things
yeah and yet we can't do it for
basketball well geez why what what what
possibly is different lobbies guys
playing the exact same building I still
love it I love the point that you make
that if they're supposed to be student
athletes amateurs why is there less
freedoms for them and there's there
supposed to be all this freedom for them
there is very little freedom for them
right we're adding extra layer of
regulation again for a union to say
we're going to protect our members and
say these are the standards in which you
can you can be an agent for us that
makes perfect sense what there's no good
way like a bachelor's degree does not
mean the guy isn't gonna swindle you we
know that there's nothing about that but
I get it that's why a union would do
that that's fine that would be their
percent would be their union it's not
I'm leaving this other place it's like
you're you know your last employer
putting a non-compete clause on you but
you're not an employer you're just a
student so and again this is not even
this isn't even accepting money
this isn't like I'm gonna pay you to go
to this school this is literally you
can't hire that person to be your
consultant on this and and that's the
part that just doesn't make any sense so
it's just a wildly inconsistent and I
just don't think it's going to help
college basketball's the one-and-done is
gone it's going to need every good
player it can get because I in
Williamson in playing here anymore
so you need all those guys to stay as
long as possible or maybe there is one
right I don't think college hockey hurts
because some top ten draft picks they
yeah you know I don't want to go to
college couple years get bigger and
better and get some education I know
that that's a positive for that sport
and college basketball is going to be
sitting there going boy we could use a
couple of those guys why are we doing
everything we can to ban them if someone
wants to play college basketball we
should do everything we can to get them
to play college basketball thanks for
filling up sometime here thanks for the
content here he'll get more interesting
soon
thank you Dan its Dan Wetzel yahoo
sports national columnist for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]